I used to hate Muslims you what you were
one of those you hated Muslims that's it
that's amazing when we say Jesus was
Jewish but he was Muslim how do you put
the two together
he's from the children of Israel
although we believe he's from that tribe
so was he
people say he's Jewish so the presses
submit to Allah so if you're submitting
to the religion as of what a prophet has
been revealed to almost you know if
you're following the true religion of
Musa so his that his ethnicity was
Jewish yeah that's his tribe that's his
try for Jesus but Jesus well he does I
think that's more appropriate so we
would say Jesus was from Benny Israel
from the children of Israel and he was
one who submitted to the will of the
creator because he said not my will be
done but God's will so he was a Muslim
and you you made the testimony of faith
that God's will be done
there's no God the affirmation the
negation the affirmation that there's
nothing worthy of worship so the creator
of heavens and earth and Muhammad is the
messenger he became Muslim why did you
why did you accept Islam
oh okay look long story this one but
basically yeah the short story I became
Muslim now joking but I used to hate
Muslims you what you were one of those
you hated Muslims that's it that's
amazing I mean yeah ironically is
through my father my father's changed
his views now me becoming Muslim but so
hate turned into love huh yeah basically
I used to be very harsh to this Muslim
kid in high school because he used to
criticize Christiani
but then I felt bad so then he gave me
some books to read I took them home and
my mother would ask me about these books
and she was interested in these books
more than I was I was just taking it for
the sake of just asking for forgiveness
for this Muslim kid because I felt a bit
but for treating him wrongly so my mum
started
reading into Islam and then she took a
liking to Islam so your mom first took a
liking into it yeah I wasn't you weren't
into you were hating the massive you are
a anti-muslim funny thing is I did have
a Muslim friend in a in primary school
and I remember asking my dad if I could
go round for lunch and have dinner I
said no stay away from these Muslims
they're terrorists and idea acceptor so
I always had this negative view of
Muslims going up into high school
because I kind of trust in my dad it's
just
yes think from a child so suddenly my
mother passed away so I trusted my
mother a lot so I trusted her judgment
so I kind of went went into looking into
Islam of open heart so that's when I
started reading this same material I
didn't well I started to read this
material seriously and that's when I
actually decided to become Muslim mhm so
that that's to - opening your mind yeah
studying it and because you were
continuing with your mother work she was
looking into she was very interested she
actually came to the conclusion that she
didn't believe Jesus because she was
raised a Christian yes the masked
mystery Jewish thing so she came to the
conclusion that she didn't believe Jesus
was the son of God yeah we as Muslims
been believe he was sent by God as a
messenger of God delivering the pure
monotheism God so last thing I want to
ask you is what advice do you have for
others who hate Muslims they hate Islam
you know they have all sorts of opinions
like you had what advice do you have for
them well the first thing I'd like to
note is that hate in Islam is a big
business for making money so whenever
there's an opportunity to make money
it's going to be out there so what I
would say is don't take the first
initial for I'm going to say the first
yeah perception from these articles the
news and whatsoever
I would ask Muslims themselves about it
like yeah
and see you see what they have to say
that's deep thank you guys so we got
John Fontaine he
the same thing he had an open heart he
prayed to the Creator
directly asked for guidance looked into
Islam he's a Muslim he's one who
submitted to the will of God
same thing for do the same thing hated
Islam now he loves Islam loves Islam
loves submission to the will of God you
can be there too I also created a guide
you let's pick it let's finish with that
this is this is that this is the Deen
show alright guys peace with you so I'm
like Oh